what up space fam goes in the air for
anime uproar in today we are going to be
talking about the quiet cute and epic
canal she's one of my favorite
characters so I'm extremely excited
about this video recently I asked you
guys on Instagram if you would rather
see how strong is Gil May or how strong
is canal video thousands voted and yo
May one so I made that video but it was
really really close so I decided to make
a bonus kono video since a lot of you
evidently wanted to see it as usual if
we can get 5,000 likes on this video I
will get started on the next one ASAP if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial ring that notification
bell or you won't know when the next
video comes out once again I've set up a
vote via Instagram stories at anime
uproar where you can vote for what video
you want to see next warning there will
be spoilers in this video we're going to
be looking at all the relevant evidence
we can find to determine how strong
canal is now without further ado let's
jump into it
canal is the adopted sister of kanay
court row and Shinobu court robe and her
character arc so far is one of the best
in the series this sixteen year old girl
has been through a lot she's seen things
vision based pun intended but in all
seriousness her upbringing was very
difficult but I think it also turned her
into a tougher and stronger person the
idea is that what doesn't kill you makes
you stronger and I think that applies to
cano if we take a long-term view of her
own story for most of us who have mostly
firstworldproblems Cano's backstories
should put her own challenges into
perspective she grew up in an abusive
and very poor household unlike most
people who have more demon based tragic
backstories humans specifically her
parents are the ones that made canals
old life a living hell if she or her
siblings cried they'd get kicked dragged
around and sometimes drowned some of her
brothers weren't careful enough and got
beaten very badly they'd be dead by the
next morning
Konoe stopped being able to cry because
crying became a matter of life and death
she had to repress her emotions in order
to survive that hellish environment
she used to be hungry sad empty in pain
and lonely every day but one day
something snapped and nothing hurt
anymore psychologically speaking she was
broke
and eventually she was sold off into
slavery by her own parents but she was
so far gone by that point that she
couldn't even feel sad about it
eventually kana and Shinobu come across
a dirty nameless girl with lice the girl
is tied up with a piece of rope a man is
leading her like she's some sort of dog
the girl is canal and the man in
question has just purchased her from her
parents
Shinobu throws money at the man and then
grabs canal and starts to run away with
her Shinobu is actually upset at first
with canal she tells her older sister
Connie that canal is completely useless
she won't do anything unless someone
tells her to and that includes eating
she'll just sit there with a rumbling
stomach she's like this because she
would have been punished or even killed
in the past if she acted without
permission as a result she lost the
ability to make decisions for herself
Kanna is more forgiving and patient than
Shinobu she smiles and says that come
out can decide on things when she's
alone by flipping a coin it's obviously
not a perfect long-term solution but it
works for the time being and as Connie
says it'll be fine if you give someone a
chance their hearts will blossom a
beautiful quote on her part the two
sisters end up raising cano and helping
to train her eventually upper moon to
DOMA kills Kanna at the funeral everyone
cried except Kanna she felt sorry at the
funeral because she couldn't cry like
the rest
Cannell was so upset that she was
sweating all over but she couldn't shed
a single tear because of her harsh
upbringing she lost the ability to cry
however no one criticized her for it
everyone including Shinobu was kind to
her later kono proves that she's strong
by passing the final selection exam
along with only four others when ki you
stopped Shinobu from hurting mezu KO
during the spider family arc it is kana
who manages to catch up to Tangier oh
and mezu KO with an expressionless face
Kanna knocks Tundra out with a kick to
the head now Tanja is spent and injured
from fighting Rui but it's still
impressive that Kanna was strong enough
to actually hurt time she was
exceptionally strong had she tries to
hurt our precious Tezuka but luckily
Medical shrinks and dodges the blade at
this point kono still can't think for
herself all she can do is follow orders
and she was told to kill demons
fortunately a crow tells kana not to
kill the bamboo biting nasgo but to
restrain her
so Cano does that instead at the
butterfly estate we find out that Cano
is a to buco
this means that she is a pillar
successor pillars hand-picked trained
and take special care of their two [ __ ]
oh and the successor does not have to
use the same breath style as their
predecessor for instance canal is
shinobis designate a successor even
though canal uses breath of the flower
style like Cana I did and Shinobu uses
breath of the insect style the fact that
she's a to GU Cote speaks to the fact
that Cano has considerable talent as
we're told in the manga she's a girl but
she's amazing she's stronger and more
talented than most male demon Slayers
while the three demons saying Musketeers
tongs reside in su and in escape are
carrying out their training at the
butterfly estate they have to compete
against Connell and they have a hard
time beating her for a long time as
we're told in the manga nobody could
hold her teacups down and nobody could
catch her tonzura even says at one point
and I quote I wonder why there's such a
huge difference even though we became
hunters at the same time and quote at
this point Connor was evidently faster
and overall stronger than the others and
the gap is pretty noticeable kinda went
so much that same to any nose
commentary' stop showing up tangelo
keeps losing and comments that kind of
smell is different
she smells very close to how pillars
smell this is huge since at this point
the three demons Ling Musketeers are
nowhere close to pillar level this was
evident when tangelo had so much trouble
fighting Rui while GU just came and beat
him without breaking a sweat
at this point it's clear that Connell is
something special
even among demon Slayers eventually
tanjo learns about the permanent full
focus breathing which the pillars ankhon
already know and he gets better but
while he's still training the butterfly
estate girls bring him gourds and tell
him to destroy them with his breathing
when tundra sees the especially hard
gourds he can't believe that a delicate
girl like canal could destroy one but
the girls say that Conell can now
destroy way bigger ones they bring one
out that's almost the size of a girl
itself punch was so shocked at how big
it is that he starts sweating after a
lot of training kundrot is eventually
able to destroy the gourds with his
breathing
after this he made just a catch cone now
in tag and beat her at the
see game however it's important to keep
in mind that this was Tundras first
victory and it was close before that he
lost many times and as we'll see this
wasn't kind of doing her absolute best
which we'll see later on when she fights
against DOMA when tundra is leaving the
butterfly estate he stops to say bye to
Cano Hunter again remarks at how amazing
she is compared to the rest of their
badge meaning him zanny sue anushka and
ganya he says that she inspires the rest
of them to do their best
Cannell doesn't say anything and then
she flips a coin to determine whether
she will speak or not after seeing the
result of the flip Cano explains to
tanjo that she uses the coin to decide
on things when she's not being
instructed but then in a beautiful
moment time Joe takes the coin throws it
and says that if it lands on heads Cano
will start living by what her heart
desires it turns out to be heads
he takes canals hands and tells her good
luck she asks how he managed to get
heads and he says it was by chance but
he would have kept flipping it until he
got heads if it came out as tails Cano
has a nice moment where she grips the
coin to her heart and then a butterfly a
state girl calls her and she a surprise
and falls over it is because of this
scene that I completely get why people
shipped on joandkaa no time to help
restart canals heart in a sense he
really conditio ship it or skip it in
the comments
I love canal so I'm totally in favor of
the ship now let's jump to the DOMA
fight where we get to see Cano at full
power
Cano actually comes in while upper moon
to DOMA is absorbing Shinobu her old
cool headed emotionless self is no more
there is a lot of emotion in her face
when she sees what's going on she's so
angry at DOMA that her veins even pop
out of her neck and face now I don't
have to tell you that upper moon to DOMA
is extremely strong his rank means that
only upper moon one kakushi bow and
moose on are stronger than him among
demons in his presence alone Cano needs
to send strength all the way to her
fingertips to keep her body from
trembling since times it'll help to
restart her heart so to speak Cano has a
changed person not only does she feel
anger her emotions make her want to
scream she doesn't need any instructions
in order to hate DOMA
she hates him because he killed her fam
dolma quickly notices that Cano has
specialized he's surprised that she
manages to survive his initial attacks
he reveals that Cannell can predict
someone's movements by looking at the
slightest movement of their shoulders
line of sight toes elbows and knees he
complements her saying that she's astute
and can do things the average
swordswoman cannot even when dolma
decides that he'll crush her eyes he's
not quick enough and she dodges his
attack he comments that she has a
well-trained body like a spring we can't
really say that dolma is going full out
but it's still impressive that Kondo man
just to stay alive and telling those
scare rides to help she survives a
number of deadly attacks she loses her
sword but Ino scheme and just to get it
back for her
coño an auskey had their hands full with
some ice clothes when dolmas face begins
to melt the poison that Shinobu had in
her body begins to take effect
considerably weakening DOMA even his ice
clones fall apart kana Annie knows k
take advantage of this opportunity and
tried to go for Domas weakened neck DOMA
still has enough strength to create a
giant ice statue in Ostia surprised but
Connell notices with her powerful eyes
that the technique is rough and lacks
precision she sees through it she
recognizes that it's a technique of
desperation in the last ditch effort
only at this point do we see canal go
all out she uses a dangerous technique
that can cause her to go blind called
flower breathing final form Vermillion
die the technique puts so much pressure
on the eyes it causes them to bleed and
as a result turns the eyes red it raises
dynamic vision to the utmost and makes
surrounding movements look dull and slow
so if you thought Kyle's vision was
impressive before now it's on a whole
other level
unlike Shinobu kana is usually strong
enough to cut off demon heads however as
she starts to cut off dolmas rotten neck
his giant statue begins freezing her her
arms start to stiffen eNOS Kay meanwhile
has been captured by the giant statue
still though he manages to help out by
throwing his swords at DOMA they hit
Cano's blade and help push it through
Domas neck the best revenge moment is
complete they manage to defeat the
insanely strong upper moon to I'd even
say that Connell was the star of the
battle while Shinobu Annie knows Kay
also played vital roles themselves after
the battle Kano's right eye is extremely
injured to the point that canal can
barely
see through it she manages to find
shinobis hairpin she remembers how she
couldn't cried during Kanye's funeral
because she was psychologically broken
she sees the ghosts of Cana and Shinobu
and they tell her she did well we get a
vision of them being reunited with their
parents in the afterlife and cano breaks
out into tears showing that she's
finally overcome her inability to cry
she no longer has to suppress her true
emotions she can feel again it is
actually Kondo who helps support Nino
skate as they walk and cry together thus
how strong is this amazingly written
character well she not only didn't get
in the way against one of the strongest
upper moans she even played a crucial
role in killing him while he knows he
got caught by the statue kana was able
to use her vermilion eye technique to
make it all the way to Domas neck then
she cuts the rotten neck within those
case help something that Shinobu would
not have been strong enough to do Cano
is truly a great successor and she
definitely deserves to become a pillar
after this at this point she is pillar
level especially when the opie
Vermillion eye technique is activated
the technique is very dangerous and she
might have permanently destroyed the
vision in her right eye but when it's
activated I would put Cannell even above
in no escape she did manage to
outmaneuver dolma in a way that he knows
he did not then even though she fought
DOMA longer she's still the one that is
supporting in US K by the end of it I
think she's probably around the level of
zani - at this point and perhaps even
stronger when using vermilion eye but
it's important to keep in mind that
vermilion eye takes a huge toll on the
body and cannot be maintained for long
you could even become permanently blind
in both eyes so it should be used as
little as possible we're just talking
hypothetically how come L might fare
against these opponents at this point at
her absolute strongest Tundra with his
access to the see-through world Dance of
the fire-god style and non self state is
definitely stronger than her at this
point
he has surpassed her since the butterfly
estate days nevertheless Cano is a
worthy successor to Shinobu and I
believe that she's surpassed her and
strengths speculations aside she's no
doubt a valuable member of the demon
slayer core and she's proven that she
can work very well with other demon
Slayers in order to defeat extremely
powerful demons and that is it for
today's video thanks for watch
if you enjoyed it make sure to smash
that like button to let me know
remember if we can get 5,000 likes then
I'll get started on the next one
ASAP if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is extremely important
hit that notification Bell so you
actually know when the next video comes
out
remember I've set up a vote via
Instagram stories at anime or or where
you can go for what video you want to
see next a big thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help make
videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro here or
to your patrons the one and only
gilgamesh baby ray nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings out just fitted Allah
beat Anatole cos at Sookie DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stand atop all
plans Steven and Radha al-hola autumn
Maddie back to 39 makoto-kun and the
world if you enjoy our work you can
support Mormon by going over to patreon
calm and I may and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private page and only this court so
check out patreon accomplished anime
uproar link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer thanks for
everything and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]